our minds give us trouble and one of the
leading ways people nowadays deal with
them is meditation sessions were you
quiet and thoughts empty the mind and
focus on just a few things outside of
you like the rustle of leaves or the
flow of water but at the school of life
we want to put forward an alternative or
rather a complementary idea we've
devised a technique based not on Eastern
thought but on ideas that come down to
us from the Western philosophical
tradition we call it a philosophical
meditation the basic premise is that a
lot of the trouble in our minds comes
from thoughts that haven't been
untangled examined and properly
confronted and that because life moves
so fast we accumulate a lot of unthought
thoughts on a daily basis insomnia for
example is chiefly the revenge of
thoughts we haven't had in the day
muddled unfocused thoughts generate a
static of anxious electricity or else
give rise to clouds of nonspecific
gloom if we've been out of touch with
our thoughts for too long we can get
snappy or suddenly enraged this is what
philosophical meditation is designed to
help us with it's a tool for
systematically clearing up our minds and
making sense of our disavowed feelings
and ideas the first priority is to set
aside a bit of time ideally some 20
minutes at least once every few days you
should sit probably in bed early in the
morning or late in the evening with a
pad of paper and anchor your
investigation of yourself around three
large questions firstly what am I
currently anxious about secondly what am
i upset about and with whom and thirdly
what am I currently excited and
ambitious about at first when asked to
respond to questions like these the mind
tends to be inarticulate and a bit
scared generally something comes to mind
but often you can't quite tell what it
is yet it might just for now
be a word or a mental image or a place
or a person's name this doesn't matter
grab the ideas when they're there
without thinking too much write
everything down however minor and don't
worry too much about its ultimate sense
philosophical meditation can be compared
to cleaning out a large clogged up
cupboard you have to take everything out
and pile it up on the bed first before
starting to sort it out so to kick off
under what am i anxious about you might
accumulate a list of concerns you
haven't looked at head-on but have
glimpsed in the course of the day it'll
be nonsense to anyone else and perhaps
almost yourself too but keep going with
all the thoughts taken out then pass
them through the sieve of a set of
questions ask what is this anxiety
really about tell the story of the
coming anxious period or challenge in
great almost tedious detail then
confront head-on everything that could
go wrong with a worrying situation or
idea now tease out how you might still
be okay even if the worst happened don't
share yourself up with false optimism
make yourself at home with the darkest
possibilities realize that almost
everything is ultimately rather
survivable then it's time to move on to
the second part of the philosophical
meditation the bit where you ask the
second big question Who am I upset with
and why the theory here is that we often
don't allow ourselves to analyze the
hurts that we receive from other people
because we're humiliatingly vulnerable
and pretend we're not yet we pay for
this full stoicism dearly for undigested
hurts generate bitterness confusion and
misdirected aggression we might go cold
on our partners with whom we're
unknowingly furious so empty the
cupboard of the mind of all its multiple
hurts take all you've written and pass
it through the following set of
questions retell yourself all of the
upsetting incidents you've faced in
great detail as if you were telling them
to an extremely kind interested and
friend then asked how might a nice
person have ended up doing what this
person did to you if they weren't
actively mean what other explanations
could there be for the hurt they've
caused lastly if this had happened to a
friend how would you advise them next
it's time to take out of the cupboard of
the mind all the thoughts that relate to
ambition and excitement
this means a range of positive emotions
tremors of interest tentative enthusiasm
delights and so on that are hovering on
the edges of consciousness ask what
recently made you feel excited envious
or desiring there's then another set of
questions to sieve these feelings
through describe your excitements as if
to a sympathetic interested friend you
need to change your life in certain ways
so what would it be to change your life
in the light of this this exciting thing
holds a clue to what's missing in your
life what might be missing if this thing
could talk what might it tell you if
this thing could try to change your life
what changes might it advise if other
parts of your life were more like this
what might they be like answering all
these questions starts the vital work of
decoding the scrambled thoughts that
normally clog up our minds the longer
we've gone without doing one of these
mental audits for more there will be to
go through philosophical meditation
doesn't magically solve problems but it
hugely helps us by creating an occasion
when we can identify our thoughts and
get them in some kind of order fears
resentments and hopes become easier to
name we get less scared of the contents
of our own minds we grow calm less
bitter and clearer about our direction
in life we start at last on the journey
to knowing ourselves properly
you